حسنًا ، مرحبًا بك مرة أخرى ، مرحبًا بك يا رفاق ،
مرحبًا بكم ، إنه أول يوم غير معتاد
في المدرسة ،
مرحباً ، هل أنت تتحرك في فحص درجات الحرارة
يرتدي قناع التباعد الاجتماعي
والصرف الصحي وهنا
في أبو ظبي هذه هي الطريقة التي
تفتح بها المدارس أبوابها
مرة أخرى كنا نشعر بالسعادة عندما
اكتشفنا أننا سنكون قادرين على إعادة
الطلاب إلى
الحرم الجامعي ، لكن ذلك جلب معنا
مجموعة كاملة من القواعد واللوائح الجديدة
والنصوص من أجل سلامتنا
وسلامة الأطفال ،
فهذه مدرسة ولكن ليس كما نعرفها ، فقد
أغلقت الأنشطة اللامنهجية الشائعة  جميع المناطق
مغلقة وحتى كيف وأين تتجول
في الحرم الجامعي
يتم التحكم فيها ، أحد الأشياء
التي تغيرت حقًا
هو أن ممراتنا هي اتجاه واحد
لذلك كان علينا وضع ملصقات
تخبر الطلاب أولاً عن المسافة
التي يحتاجون إليها  أن تكون
ولكن تظهر أيضًا اتجاهًا
يمكنهم السفر فيه
حتى يعرف الأطفال الطريقة التي يتعين عليهم السير بها في
الممرات وفي
الاتجاه الذي يتعين عليهم السير فيه  ساعدت
الفصول الدراسية في eir والطريقة التي
يخرجون بها من فصولهم الدراسية وتلك
الملصقات إلى جانب المقاعد المخصصة
أعضاء هيئة التدريس بالمدرسة على ضمان
تتبع جهات الاتصال الصارم عند الحاجة ،
لقد كان لدينا بالفعل بعض الأطفال
الذين تعاملوا مع
kovid  مع kovids في
غضون دقائق ، لدينا القدرة
على تتبع كل فصل دراسي كان فيه
الطفل وأي طلاب محتملين
كانوا على اتصال بهم لتتبع جهات الاتصال ، كان
لدينا في الواقع عدد قليل جدًا من
الأشخاص
الذين اضطررنا إلى وضعهم في الحجر الصحي
بسبب  على الرغم من أن
الأطفال لديهم خيار الدراسة
في المنزل ، يقول معظمهم
في هذه المدرسة إنهم يفضلون أن يكونوا في
الفصول الدراسية ،
فمن الجيد حقًا أن أعود إلى
المدرسة لأنني أعتقد أنني أفتقد الاتصال البشري حقًا ،
فأنا بالتأكيد أفضل
المدرسة الشخصية  على عكس المدرسة عبر الإنترنت ،
أشعر أنني رائع حقًا
في العودة إلى المدرسة أخيرًا
، لم أذهب إلى المدرسة لمدة عام تقريبًا
بالإضافة إلى بروتوكول الأمان  يقول ls put in place flickinger أن أكثر من 80 بالمائة من طاقم المدرسة قد تم تطعيمهم بالفعل ضد 19 سرية ، ولا يزال يتعين على المعلمين وأعضاء هيئة التدريس الخضوع للاختبار كل أسبوعين ، وقد ساعد ذلك في إراحة بعض الآباء ، فنحن محظوظون لأن نكون كذلك العيش في بلد وفي مدينة كانت السلطات فيها متقدمًا على الوباء في معظم الأحيان ، وأعتقد أنه كحزمة واحدة ، هو نفس القدر من الراحة الذي يمكن للوالد الحصول عليه في وسط جائحة عالمي ولكن من أجل الآباء الآخرون الذين لا يزالون غير راضين عنهم كان اكتشافًا جديدًا ، كان المنطق الذي أخذناه كعائلة ، من وجهة نظر أمنية ، اعتقدنا أنه سيكون من الأفضل لأنوشكا القيام بالتعلم في المنزل ، والعودة إلى المدرسة شيء هذا رائع حقًا ولكن مجرد مقابلة أصدقائي أثناء فترات الراحة والغداء والتحدث معهم كان أفضل جزء من يومي هو المكان الذي يمكنني فيه التخلص من التوتر وعدم وجود ذلك بعد الآن هو حزين قليلاً أعتقد
قد لا تعود المدارس أبدًا إلى ما
كانت عليه من قبل ،
ولكن على الأقل هنا في أبو ظبي ، فإن هذه
المدرسة واثقة من أن لديها ما
يلزم للتكيف مع هذا الوضع الطبيعي الجديد
بيكي أندرسون سي إن إن أبو ظبي